i can go into walmart heck i don't even
have to wear pants nobody wears a mask
at walmart
i can go get a pink cockatoo for my
christmas tree but i can't go and dine
outdoors at a restaurant
in early december restaurateur andrew
gruel
responded to california governor gavin
newsom's statewide ban on
outdoor dining with a video that went
viral
i can go to target amazon's making tons
of money all big business is getting
rich
okay outdoor dining does not lead to any
of that
therefore screw that we're staying open
outdoors
it's that simple i'm not an [ __ ] the
governor rule is the founder and owner
of slapfish a growing fast casual
restaurant chain based in huntington
beach california
he's a widely recognized culinary
innovator
and a familiar face on the food network
and other cooking channels how did you
name your restaurant slap fish
it's fish so fresh it'll slap you during
the pandemic he's gained prominence as
an
unabashed critic of arbitrary rules that
put
small business operators at the beck and
call of hypocritical politicians
who ignore basic science reason sat down
to talk with gruel about what it's been
like to run a business with government
at all levels arbitrarily flipping the
on off switch
why innovation is central to both
capitalism and cuisine
and why he'll never open another
franchise in california
andrew grull thanks for talking to
reason thank you for having me
summarize how difficult this year has
been
running a food business it's been all
about the extremes extreme highs and
extreme lows
the interesting thing though is is that
it comes in phases right so what we saw
in california in phases was the first
two weeks four weeks six weeks of the
lockdown
we frankly were all living the cliche
that we were in it together i mean
you know i was supporting the lockdown
to some degree within the restaurant
space because we all didn't know what
was happening
right so it was this fact-finding
mission for a few weeks
right we all know flatten the curve etc
etc and everybody was kind of in it so
our first pivot once we got shut down
was okay what can we do as a restaurant
and this is how our mindset goes as
business owners what can we do to help
the community
so we opened up for feeding all the kids
who couldn't be get school lunches
all first responders but then over time
right we started to learn a little bit
more
and then it was more lockdown
more restriction more uh crut
you know they really was about crushing
the mindset of the consumer not
intentionally i'm not saying that was
the intentional
goal but after about a month it really
it was the fear set in and then it just
starts to germinate
in the community right in the in the
behavior
of people within the community meaning
that they weren't coming out for food or
no they weren't coming out and
and if you just do a general sample
across
social platforms on a hyper local level
that's where you can really kind of see
through the conversation how scared
people were
to actually go out what we saw time and
time and time again
is with every lockdown there was
a massive sect of people who were losing
their jobs
and it was just this glib ho-hum
attitude from the governments locking us
down you know because
people over profits right these sound
bites
were were just constantly being
masqueraded
around to make the business owners and
the workers within the industries that
were being vilified
feel guilty so specifically the
restaurant industry
was being vilified as a vector of spread
for coronavirus
when the health department of america's
most populous county los angeles
banned outdoor dining in late november
2020 ahead of the winter holidays
policymakers offered no evidence that
eating outdoors
was a significant source of covet spread
when asked if there were
any known covet cases that could be
attributed to outdoor dining
the county's public health director
dodged the question
i don't have those numbers in front of
me but i will be happy to
you know work with our communications
team and and we'll get those numbers
county data showed that restaurants were
highly compliant with coveted health
guidelines
and the industry didn't make the
county's top five list of covet exposure
sites really has to do with the goal of
trying to keep people
at home not a comment on
the relative safety of outdoor dining
multiple judges ruled against state and
local bans
though the decisions it had little
practical effect most california
restaurants
including rules were limited to takeout
only
for months viscerally it makes sense
you've got these
small spaces where people are on top of
one another and therefore they have to
be these vectors are spread right
but then when you actually pull apart
the layers and you think about it we're
trained to be
safe and sanitary every single
restaurant worker has a food handler's
card within that food handler's card and
that certification
you learn everything from various steps
of entry service etc
through the restaurant from bacteria
material data safety sheets we are
basically on the front line of trying to
create environments that are safe and
sanitary
that's what we do but yet we are
now being vilified as the vectors of
spread when
frankly the data didn't show that you
know how do you respond when you get
shut down for outdoor dining which is
not a cause of spread
and that's like the thing that's keeping
you afloat here in southern california
and actually across the nation you
started to see a lot of investment
in things like outdoor dining patios and
expanding patios to outside but then you
also did see a deregulation on things
like having alcohol outside right now
you were allowed to take alcohol out
you were allowed to drink outside
whereas before perhaps you weren't based
upon
the abc rules so you start to see
restaurants effectively
spill out into parking lots on the
streets and it was great right going
into the summertime
everybody was giving everyone else a
high five about this we saw it in in
cold climates and hot climates now go
into
fall winter time southern california is
positioned
to be the restaurant mecca by virtue of
our weather here
outdoor dining you started to see
restaurants pick back up again the
economic simulation
and then they shut down outdoor dining
no data no science and the minute they
did that i said this vocally i said
watch within two to three weeks of
shutting down you're gonna start to see
a spike
because the unintended or intended
consequence of shutting down outdoor
dining is you're going to drive people
indoors and i have anecdotal evidence of
so many people saying hey
we had plans to go out and dine with our
weekly dining group outdoors at javier's
or whatever restaurant it is
and when they shut down outdoor dining
we all just ended up going inside and
having a house party we all got covered
right cases spiked when they shut down
outdoor dining and still to this day
they will not admit the mistake
associated with that nobody was
expecting
anyone to shut down outdoor dining
that's just insane so
people had hired to be able to serve
through the wintertime
and when they shut down outdoor dining
it was the last week of november here in
california
it was every restaurateur's
nightmare to have to let go of the
majority of their staff that's when the
survival mode then kicked in because we
were already just hanging on by a thread
it was in a moment of desperation
following the second mandated closure of
the majority of california restaurants
that grew
unloaded on governor newsome at every
single juncture along the way here from
the beginning
shutdown to today we've listened to all
of the advice from our government
officials
only to be shut down over and over and
over again and then not compensated for
the elements that we put in place in our
businesses in order to protect our
customers
newsom now faces a recall election after
a petition drew more than two million
signatures people
creating rules that are crushing
businesses and crushing local economies
not following their own rules and being
on display
then flaunting that behavior and having
a real
smug response to it is the epitome of
elitism
and that's what we all talk about we
joke about how there's two categories of
people you've got the elite and then
you've got the
you know the proletariat if you will
you've got the workers and
it couldn't be more uh it couldn't be
couldn't be more clear
than the past four or five months i
would say because
there's almost been um a bubble of
safety around our elected leaders when
it comes to coronavirus uh
from having you know the best health
care the best testing immediate access
to vaccines right every single piece
that's rolled out every
every kind of lever that's supposed to
help
when it comes to the pandemic
celebrities
the uber wealthy and our elected
officials always get first dibs at
gruel says newsome has targeted him for
political retribution
so about four or five days after my
little social media ran against newsome
we got served by the labor commissioner
a full blanket investigation on every
single business that i'm associated with
absolutely no trigger no specific
complaint we've never had a labor law
violation
there is no basis in this random
investigation and furthermore the
investigation is happening
at a time where everybody knows the
restaurant industry is crushed right
so this investigation comes down we've
had to spend now
well over twenty thousand dollars on
legal fees in trying to provide
three years of documentation on every
single business they've asked we've
turned that around within five six days
hours and hours and hours of work still
to absolutely no
no response as to what triggered the
investigation what have you
it's political targeting how long will
it take for that to be resolved you know
have absolutely no idea and it's been
looming i mean it keeps us awake at
night because
of the fact that there is not absolutely
nothing that we can do
there's no logic no reason behind any of
this and furthermore
if they just toss it to the side it's
not like my legal fees are going to be
covered
it's it's it's the bureaucratic red tape
that they use if you speak out
against the institution of government
here in california your twitter feed is
fantastic and i
recommend everybody check it out um but
it you you were talking about how the
enhanced
federal and state unemployment benefits
also made it hard for you to staff your
restaurant
what was going on there and what was the
unintended consequence
of giving people you know more money to
you know for unemployment
in the very beginning when the
government offered i think was 600
on top of what the state was offering
for unemployment it worked out here in
california it was about 1100
a week i think you could get max right
so we did have
a lot of team members who initially we
we did
lay everybody off because we didn't know
what was going to happen they told us we
could be in the shutdown for x amount of
days
what have you um but right away as we
started helping out with the community
and building some business
our business came back and we also
needed those employees back so we
started reaching out to everybody and a
lot of people were like look i'm making
1100 right now not working i've got
books i want to read
i've got classes i want to take online
i'm going to
really wait this thing through i'm going
to take the money as opposed to coming
back and working
and what was hilarious was that when i
posted that little anecdote right not
using names
and i'm not targeting these look if i
was 19 years old
and i was a server in a restaurant and i
could make
1500 as a server working 50 hours a week
or i could make 1100
sitting at home reading books learning
an instrument all the things that you
always say you want to do
heck i would do it too no shame on them
at all it was just the
kind of framework that was established
but when i talked about that everybody's
response to me was well you're not
paying your employees enough that's
because you're a greedy business owner
the only reason they're not coming back
is because maybe you should pay them
more
no no that's not the point right like i
said even if it's two thousand dollars
that they were making by working here
versus eleven hundred
it's merely the fact that people are
being paid a significant sum of money
to not work it incentivizes that and
that's what we saw
became virtually impossible for months
to hire back employees and this was
across all of our stores
what do you think the long-term damage
will be to the kind of food
service industry we don't know what the
long-term damage is going to be yet and
i think it's way too early to start
counting casualties so this is
you know articles right now that say oh
well you know it's all over and the
restaurant industry didn't do as poor as
everybody thought that they were going
to do and stop feeling sorry for them
that's akin to counting casualties in a
plane crash right the plane is crashing
two people on the plane have a heart
attack plane hasn't hit the ground yet
and everybody's saying look only two
people died in this plane crash well
wait until the plane hits the ground
because we're free-falling right now and
we don't know the effect
that all of these uh regulations
all these lockdowns and all of the
economic manipulation
is going to have on micro industries but
or the economy as a whole
in the long run and you know long run
short run
we could be looking at certain effects
in six months 12 months 24 months but
it is my contention that we haven't seen
the worst yet
gruel has made it big in california but
he's a garden state native working some
of his first restaurant jobs on the
jersey shore
he moved into fine dining after working
as a chef at a boston ritz carlton
and other high-end restaurants gruel's
jersey roots have led him toward the
kind of messy
fast but high quality food on offer at
slapfish which started as a food truck
before growing to a national chain
of two dozen establishments in 10 states
and the uk
my first job was working with the short
hills hilton dishwasher prep cook
outdoor pool boy you know working and
dining
in new jersey restaurants certainly
establishes the right dna if you will
um and one would hope yeah now that's
that's translated to uh
sloppy sandwiches although you know
having spent years working in the world
of fine dining as well
it's now my mission to combine the
quality of fine dining between two
pieces of bread
who are your kind of chef heroes or
cooking heroes
definitely bourdain of course uh you
know a little little jersey feel
right there um carl ruiz who recently
passed
uh who you know was a phenomenal chef
burgeoning star in the food network
scene but also just a good
down-to-earth uh jersey new york chef uh
you know when i look at some of the
culinary heroes beyond
you know jacques penn we had talked
about with the howard johnson's
connection
can you talk about how innovation in
cooking uh and in preparing food
how does that intersect with regulation
coming down from you know public health
authorities or whatever talk to any chef
and all they're going to come back to
are fundamentals
right cooking is all about fundamentals
and fundamentals of french mother sauces
fundamentals
of basic technique and then fundamentals
to even
kitchen hierarchy sanitation flow of
service right it's always about the
fundamentals but the primary piece
of food is the ingredients that go into
the food
so when you look across the landscape
the culinary landscape and you see
what's hot and what's popular and
there's a lot of kind of cliches and
there's also a lot of
people trying to be a bit avant-garde
and going over the top just to get that
quick flash in a pan pun intended but
really the chefs that are doing
something new
are only focusing on ingredients and
they're getting the highest quality
ingredients but they're also getting the
freshest and the newest ingredients and
it comes down to the soil
so when it so when we bring the idea of
regulation into
the growth of food new cuisines quality
of food
it's all about having high quality food
that's unadulterated right
it doesn't have to go through the system
of
government which effectively pulls not
just flavor out of the food it pulls art
out of the food and you're left with
cardboard
and what we've seen over the decades is
we've seen the quality of food
let's use an apple as it just gets
constantly
modified genetically modified in many
cases in order to make it
more transportable in order to make it
more approachable
right i mean we think about shape when
it comes to food is we've actually lost
not just the nutrition but the quality
of the food right compared to 20 years
ago
you know much less 50 years ago american
food offerings at every level is just so
much better or more varied i mean
there's bad stuff but there's great
stuff
what is what's driving you know that
kind of renaissance and revolution and
you know it's a perpetual revolution in
new
interesting weird fun stuff sometimes
it's a return to basic sometimes
it's coming up with something totally
different what what's driving that in
america
nowadays what drives a lot of food
innovation is media and social media
and that's somewhat of a a a vanity
arena
and that's good and bad right it gets
people to be more aware of their food it
gets people to go out more to basically
say look where i am look what i ate look
what i did
but at the same rate it's very surface
level so
i think that we're seeing a change
across the food landscape because of
that
element of it but i still think once
again deep down i come down to the
fundamentals and i come down to the
ingredients and what's driving
chefs who are artists to be able to
create new dishes and create new genres
of food
is trying to find new ways to take
high high high quality ingredients and
present them to the diner
in a different literally a different
vessel
and figuratively a different arena his
experience working with seafood on the
west coast drove gruel's interest in
ocean conservation he serves as director
of a non-profit project at the aquarium
of the pacific in long beach california
called seafood for the future where he
aims to combat
overfishing by developing sustainable
open ocean aquaculture techniques
or fish farming in the pacific ocean
well the ocean is everything
right i mean you can take any topic and
you can bring it back to the ocean
okay we are going to work on the manson
family murders and the kennedy
assassination
maybe later but so talk about the ocean
well psychosis and
depression are a result of not having
enough omega-3s and dha's in your diet
which
specifically come from seafood let's
talk about the oceans talk about the
ocean economy
number one it's still the wild west all
right it is not regulated the same way
that terrestrial farming is
or and by that i'm referring to both
aquaculture and wild capture fisheries
what we also saw over the past
50 years is the most positive and
amazing display of ocean resilience so
when i talk about overfishing right
which is really simple it's
it's basically taking a specific seafood
species to virtual extinction or
commercial extinction because
it can't reproduce anymore we fi
overfished it and we saw that in the 80s
with cod
atlantic cod fishery which was the
biggest fishery
in the world at one point um we saw it
with
swordfish right if you remember that
campaign give swordfish a break
so a lot of government agencies and this
is where government can do
can do good they came in and they
started to do a lot of science on the
ocean they said okay we we understand
that the biomass of this particular
species is x in order for it to hit its
maximum sustainable yield we can only
catch y amount each year and then there
are these fishing quotas
right and you have these private
fishermen who go out and then obviously
they can only catch a certain amount
which then forced them to digress into
other fisheries right it really
diversified the fishing industry and
that was a great thing and what we saw
was success
right now that particular swordfish
fishery is at its maximum sustainable
yield
atlantic cod the fishery has been
refreshed
that is about ocean resilience we don't
use the ocean enough
in order to um you know solve some of
our environmental problems that we've
created on land
those are success stories but instead
we're just brow beating day in and day
out with this
fear that we're going to run out of
seafood by 2050 there was a study it was
um was it boris worm who did this
seafood's going to be and ted danson did
a huge
huge piece on it um and it was about how
we're going to overfish the ocean we're
going to be eating jellyfish by 2050.
well the study was junk
it was junk science never even came
close to it and it didn't happen
the reason it didn't happen is because
of the presence of aquaculture 55
60 of the seafood consumed worldwide is
because of
aquaculture and specifically open ocean
aquaculture
behind oil and automobiles one of the
largest trade deficits in the united
states is actually seafood we import
80 plus percent of the seafood that we
consume here in the united states
well why do we do that is because we're
importing farmed
seafood well why are we importing farm
seafood because we don't have
uh the framework for an open ocean
aquaculture policy so that's like
that's creating farms that are out in
the ocean
and so that solves a lot of problems
right the farming of fish
it decreases the pressure off the wild
stock so you still now have
the economic viability of a wild fishery
um wild capture fisheries right and then
you've all because they're catching a
lot less now there's the innovation and
technological innovation associated with
farming fish and being
efficient at farming fish in the open
ocean so when they started farming fish
in the 80s right
the amount of feed that you needed wild
fish in order to feed farm fish the
ratio was like
for every pound of farm fish you would
grow five pounds of wild fish you'd have
to catch
right that feed conversion ratio is
incredibly inefficient why farm fish if
you're taking more wild fish to feed the
farm fish
well nowadays the feed conversion ratio
is like point five to one
i mean the efficiency that we've reached
is unbelievable
this is all being done outside of u.s
waters open
ocean aquaculture is controversial among
certain types of foodies right
is that merely personal interest or
economic interest masquerading as a
public health concern
or is there something to that both it's
both so it's just mainly it's
misinformation
um the the hysteria the sensationalism
and the press related to
the fear of you know the danger of
aquaculture and farm seafood
is unbelievable and there was billions
of dollars that have been
poured into a demarketing campaign to
demarcate aquaculture
and i don't want to point out any
particular agencies that done this
would be nice if you did though name
names just follow the money in the
beginning of the alaskan seafood
marketing
institute was putting tons of money into
demarketing farm seafood because their
number one export of course wild salmon
was now competing with a farmed atlantic
salmon
which was being farmed at a cost much
lower than it takes to
capture process and sell the wild
species now as a chef
they're two totally different species
atlantic salmon farmed atlantic salmon
compared to a wild alaskan fish is an
apple two and
a banana right two totally different
species no reason
to be de-marketing one versus the other
if you actually had invested
in promoting farmed atlantic salmon all
you know
all boats rise with a high tide right
higher seafood consumption
but i will say this because of that and
all of the fear-mongering and the fact
that farm seafood is going to kill you
and then furthermore pcbs and mercury
and all of these sensationalized stories
our per capita consumption of seafood in
the united states is one of the lowest
of most countries as a result of that
what do we eat chicken
beef what do they eat corn soy high in
omega-6 fatty acids
having a a an over abundance of omega-6
fatty acids in your diet leads to things
like hypertension heart failure all of
these health deficiencies
because we're eating junk food we're
putting junk into our bodies
there's a lack of dha omega-3 fatty
acids that
can only be found in high quality
seafood six of the eight leading causes
of death in the u.s can be alleviated
through regular consumption of
the right omega-3 fatty acids so
these headlines have now forced people
to eat less seafood they're so confused
about it they get up to the lunch
counter it's like well
just give me the chicken right give me
the chicken so we now have
the real pandemic that's underneath the
pandemic we're in right now
is the health crisis in america obesity
what's in our diets the lack of
nutrition in our food the hollow food
that we're eating
and that's been perpetuated by it over
regulated food system
and the food system has now been
consolidated into
the government right so it's basically
corporatism at its worst
done through food and that's what's
being fed to kids that's what's being
fed
because it's economically more viable
to and financially for the economy to be
able to mass produce crap food
than to buy something locally from a
local farmer's market right
and i've heard on many occasions
economists make the argument about
comparative advantage well
if i buy this tomato locally and it
costs three dollars to grow and sell
this tomato here locally or i could buy
the same tomato
you know that's shipped in mass-produced
in mexico for a dollar
technically doesn't that mean that i can
have the tomato and still have an
extra two dollars to spend in my local
economy so that actually helps the
economy
well that argument is flawed and the
reason why it's flawed is because of the
quality of the tomato they're bringing
in
is not the same quality in addition to
the fact that the social element of
buying local eating local
co-mingling locally by going to the
farmer's market
right when's the last time you saw
somebody in albertson sitting around
having a political conversation sipping
on an espresso
how do you have fresh seafood in
missouri
most if not 99 of all seafood is frozen
at sea
so there still isn't regulation
associated with fresh versus frozen
all sushi has to be frozen that's how
they kill the parasites so once again
the idea that frozen seafood is a bad
thing has been implanted
in our minds i always look for frozen
seafood i'll take the frozen seafood any
day because it's been
pulled out of the water flash frozen
right and when you thaw it it's
basically unfreezing time
do you want that or do you want the
piece of fish that's you know three
weeks
um yeah
andrew gruel what what kind of is your
real name lipschitz like
where does that name come from i wish my
last name was mayonnaise or ketchup so
i'm something in the condiment
category so so gruel is a german name um
french german they don't know exactly
where it started and uh
you know i just i can only imagine at
some point in my
in my family um we were just we were
scooping porridge for soldiers somewhere
do you uh do you get a lot of uh jokes
made about oh my god it's
the culinary school was the greatest
yeah um uh
so you know chef gruel that was right uh
johnson and wales proud johnson in wales
yes yes johnson wales before i went to
johnson wells i went to a small liberal
arts college up in maine
bates college oh yeah um and uh you know
protested capitalism and smoked pot
so well what flipped you then was it the
pot or was it owning your business that
made you become a capitalist well i mean
my first
my first real foray into understanding
business was
marijuana because in maine
you've got an agrarian economy
and then you have three incredibly
expensive liberal arts colleges
colby bates and bowden all within this
uh you know kind of
45 50 mile radius and the
incredibly wealthy kids that go to
school there mind you i went on a
running scholarship
and i was just a jersey kid blue-collar
jersey kid
and you have all these kids who
they want to smoke pot and maine has
always been very
um decriminalized if you will
so what was the first thing i saw was i
saw a need and i was a long distance
runner i wasn't a pot smoker at all
right but i saw a need and the greatest
thing was you know you don't get high on
your own supply so i was the prime
candidate to be able to
address their business needs amazing um
you know as we
uh final question um you know as as we
seem to be coming out of the pandemic
uh one of the problems with crises is
that they institute a lot of policies
that last forever
uh so you know there's a reason why
we're taking our shoes off
you know 20 years after 9 11. um you
know and oftentimes the policies have
nothing to do with safety or anything
what are a couple of regulations that
you really want to see go away that were
implemented over the last year
yep well that's a great point that you
bring up and i like really quickly
before i answer that i'll also ask
another question
back more just pose it but are there any
scenarios with policy whereby
there's been regulations put in place in
our everyday lives
but hundreds of them thousands of them
and then they've been removed
you talk about the shoe thing i just
don't know a story so well this
here's a question for you you know you
mentioned before the kind of takeaway
liquor sales and the idea you know that
stores would sell pre-made cocktails
or you would be allowed to drink out on
the sidewalks and stuff and in many
cases
you know the laws governing alcohol
consumption go back to the colonial
period
um do you think there's do you think
some of those laws that kind of loosen
things up do you think they'll stick
around or will
those be pulled back and and the old
laws put in place yeah i think that the
areas where the laws have now been
loosened they're going to get tightened
up again right so
specifically alcohol sales the ability
to take out alcohol
this gray area now between the various
types of liquor licenses here in
california where you can do some things
that you otherwise weren't able to do
that's all going to go away which is
also something that i don't think i know
i don't fully understand when i talk to
restaurateurs
the gradations of alcohol licenses in
every state in the country and they're
different
sometimes county by county of what
you're allowed to sell
you know even within a restaurant it's
just bewildering you have a beer and
wine license here in california you
actually have
you cannot serve just rice that doesn't
count as food you actually need
something that's been cooked over a
specific device that that requires a
hood
right so if i have pokey and rice and
that's my meal
that doesn't count as food by the
california standards and i wouldn't be
able to have my beer and wine license
that's amazing so what are what are the
what are the worst laws that you hope
do go away that have been put in place
just in the past year
well first and foremost i think that uh
the you know one thing that's been great
for restaurants through the pandemic has
been the
access to capital right and one of the
reasons why
we're seeing a destruction of small
independent restaurants throughout
america
before the pandemic was just there was
no access to capital the only people who
had the capital
were the big private equity firms or
family funds um
you know sba does nothing for small
businesses when it comes to restaurants
the only way you can get an sba loan is
if you actually have the money to back
it
right so then you don't need the exactly
so the access to capital that's been
huge and i hope that that remains
because that will help
small independence where is that coming
from well it's just all been loosened up
i mean whether whether it's through the
ppp
itself specifically or any of these new
stimulus programs that have been
introduced through the restaurant
or the uh the rescue relief plans those
have been helpful and i think will
continue to be helpful now the only
fear that i have is all this money has
been earmarked but it's being
distributed through government agencies
and what we know is is that it's like
you know i make the joke
is that you take a you take a cup of
mayonnaise right and you eventually want
to transfer it from one cup across to 10
cups
well by the time you get to that final
cup you got half the mayonnaise in there
because it's stuck to the sides of this
cup
that's government right the money's
gonna stick to the sides of government
very quickly and we're not gonna
actually see all of that money
so i go back to the i'm bouncing around
here but you asked about the fund we
raised
we've raised almost 400 thousand dollars
and we've distributed it within 24 hours
of receiving it
every single penny if not more because
we've been matching some of that my wife
and i
as we kind of go through week by week
you look at unemployment
who the hell knows where that money's
going right i mean you've got some
jabroni
um in jail up here who's getting you
know
unemployment checks and my employees or
some of them are still waiting on their
checks from when we laid them off in
april
so if we can start to see some of this
money that is being
printed which really is you know where's
this money coming from but if if that
money
actually is distributed directly
to businesses and to people as opposed
to going through government agencies
then i actually think that it will be
helpful to the economy but that doesn't
seem to be the case
all right we're going to leave it there
chef andrew grull proprietor of slapfish
thanks for talking to reason
thank you so much
[Music]